Doutor, muito café faz mal para quem tem
doença de rashimoto? Olha só, gente,
quantas vezes você já ouviu falar aquela
história de que café faz mal para
tireoide? Pois é, hoje eu quero bater um
papo com vocês sobre isso, porque tem
muita gente com Hashimuto por aí tomando
suas xícaras de café e se perguntando se
fazendo mal ou não. E sabe o que é mais
interessante? A resposta não é tão
simples quanto um sim ou não. Vem comigo
que eu vou contar tudinho para vocês.
Sabe aquela sensação gostosa de acordar
e já sentir o cheiro de café? Pois é.
Imagina você tendo que abrir mão disso.
Mas calma, não precisa entrar em pânico
ainda. A questão principal aqui, minha
gente, não é exatamente o café em si,
mas sim como ele interage com a sua
medicação. É tipo aquela história do
remédio que não pode tomar com leite,
OK? A mesma coisa acontece com a livro
toroxina, que é o hormônio sintético que
a maioria das pessoas com rachimoto
precisa tomar porque tem hipotiroidismo.
Deixa eu explicar melhor. Quando você
tem Hashimoto, seu sistema de defesa,
sistema imune fica meio confuso e começa
a atacar a própria tireóde. É como se o
corpo criasse uma guerra civil interna,
OK? E aí a tireóide, coitada, vai
perdendo a capacidade de produzir os
hormônios de maneira correta. Por isso a
gente precisa repor com a livro tiroxina
ou T4. Mas aqui que tá o pulo do gato.
Estudos recentes mostram que se você
tomar o seu cafezinho logo depois do
remédio, pode reduzir a absorção em até
50%.
50%, gente, é muita coisa. Mas pera aí,
não é para jogar a cafeteira fora ainda.
A medicina funcional nos ensina a olhar
o quadro todo, não só um pedacinho. E
sabe o que que a gente descobriu? O
problema não é o café em si, mas o
timing. É toda uma questão de relógio
biológico e paciência. A recomendação é
super simples. Tome sua oliva tiroxina
até 4 assim que acordar só com água,
espere pelo menos 30 a 60 minutos antes
de tomar aquele cafezinho sagrado.
Alguns especialistas são mais rigorosos
e falam em 2 horas, mas olha, na prática
30 a 60 minutos já resolve bem o
problema pra maioria das pessoas. Agora
vamos falar sobre quantidade, porque tem
gente que toma café como se fosse água,
né? Para quem tem rachimoto, o ideal é
manter na faixa de dois a três xícaras
por dia. Por que isso? Porque o excesso
de cafeína pode piorar alguns sintomas
que já são chatos por si só. Ansiedade,
poptação, insônia. Imagina só, você já
tá lidando com o cansaço do
hipotiroidismo, ainda por cima não
consegue dormir direito por causa do
excesso de café. É tiro no pé, né,
pessoal? Tem uma coisa bem bacana que eu
sempre falo pros meus pacientes. Cada
corpo é um corpo. Cada corpo é único.
Tem gente que é super sensível à cafeína
e com a xícara já tá todo ligado, todo
elétrico. Outros tomam três e estão de
boa. O segredo é observar como é que seu
corpo reage. Faça um teste. Passa um mês
sem cafeína e vê como você se sente.
Depois reintroduz aos poucos e observa.
É tipo ser um detetive do seu próprio
corpo. E olha que interessante, a
cafeína pode até ter alguns efeitos
positivos. Estudos mostram que ela tem
propriedades antioxidantes, pode
melhorar um metabolismo e até ajudar na
função cognitiva. Mas aqui entra aquela
máxima da medicina funcional, a dose faz
o veneno. O que que é remédio para uns?
pode ser problema para outros,
especialmente quando falamos de doenças
autoimunes, como é o caso do Rashimoto.
Ah, e tem mais uma coisa importante, não
é só café que tem cafeína, viu? Tem no
chá preto, chá verde, mate, chocolate,
refrigerantes, a base de cola. Tudo isso
conta na sua cota diária e alguns
suplementos pré-treino também são
carregados de cafeína. Então fica
esperto ou esperta com a matemática da
cafeína do seu corpo. Deixa eu contar
uma coisa que poucos médicos falam. O
estado do seu intestino também
influencia. Se você tem disbiose
intestinal, cro intestino irritável ou
qualquer alteração de permeabilidade
intestinal, absorção tanto da medicação
quanto dos nutrientes pode ficar
comprometida. E aí o café pode ser mais
um fator irritante. Na medicina
funcional a gente sempre olha pro
intestino como o segundo cérebro. E no
caso do Hashimoto, isso é fundamental.
Sabe o que que eu acho mais legal? É que
pequenas mudanças podem fazer uma baita
diferença na sua vida. Não precisa virar
a vida de cabeça para baixo. É só
ajustar os horários, prestar atenção na
quantidade e, principalmente, escutar o
que seu corpo tá dizendo. Se depois do
café você fica muito agitado, agitada,
tremor, suando frio, seu corpo tá
gritando que tá demais. E para finalizar
nosso papo, eu vou deixar uma reflexão
aqui. O rashimoto não é só sobre
tireoide, é sobre inflamação, é sobre
autoimunidade, é sobre estilo de vida. O
café é só uma pecinha desse
quebra-cabeça gigante. O importante é
você encontrar o seu equilíbrio, fazer
os ajustes necessários e, principalmente
não se privar completamente das coisas
que te dão prazer, porque qualidade de
vida também faz parte do tratamento, né?
Então é isso, pessoal. Café e rachimoto
podem conviver em harmonia, sim, é só
respeitar os horários, não exagerar na
dose e ficar de olho em como seu corpo
responde. E lembra, cada caso é um caso.
O que funciona pro seu vizinho pode não
funcionar para você. Por isso é tão
importante esse olhar individualizado da
medicina funcional. Cuida bem da sua
tiroide, mas cuida com carinho, sem
neuras. A vida já é complicada demais
pra gente ficar criando mais problemas,
não é? Um brinde com uma xícara de café.
No horário certo, claro.
Compartilhe os vídeos, faça bem. A vida
de alguém pode mudar também no canal do
Dor além do se envolva. Ah.